PETER SZOLOVITS: OK.
So today and next
Tuesday, we're talking
about the role of natural
language processing in machine
learning in health care.
And this is going to
be a heterogeneous kind
of presentation.
Mainly today, I'm going to
talk about stuff that happened
or that takes
advantage of methods
that are not based on neural
network representations.
And on Tuesday, I'm
going to speak mostly
about stuff that does depend on
neural network representations,
but I'm not sure where the
boundary is going to fall.
I've also invited
Dr. Katherine Liao
over there, who will
join me in a question
and answer session and interview
like we did a couple of weeks
ago with David.
Kat is a rheumatologist in the
Partners HealthCare system.
And you'll actually be
hearing about some of the work
that we've done
together in the past
before we go to the interview.
So roughly, the outline
of these two lectures
is that I want to talk
a little bit about why
we care about clinical text.
And then I'm going to talk
about some conceptually very
appealing, but practically
not very feasible
methods that involve
analyzing these narrative
texts as linguistic entities,
as linguistic objects
in the way that a linguist
might approach them.
And then we're going to talk
about what is very often done,
which is a kind of term
spotting approach that says,
well, we may not be able to
understand exactly everything
that goes on in the
narratives, but we
can identify certain words
and certain phrases that
are very highly indicative
that the patient has
a certain disease,
a certain symptom,
that some particular
thing was done to them.
And so this is a lot
of the bread and butter
of how clinical research
is done nowadays.
And then I'll go on to
some other techniques.
So here's an example.
This is a discharge
summary from MIMIC.
When you played with MIMIC, you
notice that it's de-identified.
And so names and
things are replaced
with square brackets, star,
star, star kinds of things.
And here I have replaced--
we replaced those
with synthetic names.
So Mr. Blind isn't
really Mr. Blind,
and November 15 probably really
isn't November 15, et cetera.
But I wanted something
that read like real text.
So if you look at something
like this, you see that Mr.
Blind is a 79-year-old
white white male--
so somebody repeated a word--
with a history of diabetes
mellitus and inferior MI,
who underwent open repair of
his increased diverticulum
on November 13 at some--
again, that's not the
name of the actual place--
medical center.
And then he developed
hematemesis,
so he was spitting up
blood, and was intubated
for respiratory distress.
So he wasn't breathing well.
So these are all really
important things about what
happened to Mr. Blind.
And so we'd like to be able
to take advantage of this.
And in fact, to give
you a slightly more
quantitative version of this,
Kat and I worked on a project
back around 2010
where we were looking
at trying to understand what
are the genetic correlates
of rheumatoid arthritis.
And so we went to the research
patient data repository
of Mass General and the
Brigham Partners HealthCare,
and we said, OK, who
are the patients who
have been billed for a
rheumatoid arthritis visit?
And there are many thousands
of those people, OK?
And then we selected
a random set of I
think 400 of those patients.
We gave them to
rheumatologists, and we said,
which of these people actually
have rheumatoid arthritis?
So these were based
on billing codes.
So what would you guess is
the positive predictive value
of having a billing code
for rheumatoid arthritis
in this data set?
I mean, how many people
think it's more than 50%?
OK, that would be
nice, but it's not.
How many people think
it's more than 25%?
God, you guys are getting
really pessimistic.
Well, it also isn't.
It turned out to be something
like 19% in this cohort.
Now, before you
start calling, you
know, the fraud
investigators, you
have to ask yourself why is
it that this data is so lousy,
right?
And there's a systematic reason,
because those billing codes
were not created
in order to specify
what's wrong with the patient.
They were created
in order to tell
an insurance company
or Medicare or somebody
how much of a payment is
deserved by the doctors
taking care of them.
And so what this means is
that, for example, if I
clutch my chest and go, uh,
and an ambulance rushes me over
to Mass General and they
do a whole bunch of tests
and they decide that I'm
not having a heart attack,
the correct billing
code for that visit
is myocardial infarction.
Because of course
the work that they
have to do in order to figure
out that I'm not having a heart
attack is the same
as the work they
would have had to do to figure
out that I was having a heart
attack.
And so the billing codes--
we've talked about
this a little bit
before-- but they are a very
imperfect representation
of reality.
So we said, well, OK.
What if we insisted
that you have
three billing codes for
rheumatoid arthritis
rather than just one.
And that turned out to raise
the positive predictive value
all the way up to 27%.
So we go, really?
How could you get
billed three times?
Right?
Well, the answer is that you
get billed for, you know,
every aspirin you
take at the hospital.
And so for example,
it's very easy
to accumulate three billing
codes for the same thing
because you go see a
doctor, the doctor bills you
for a rheumatoid
arthritis visit,
he or she sends you
to a radiologist
to take an X-ray of your
fingers and your joints.
That bill is another
billing code for RA.
The doctor also
sends you to the lab
to have a blood
draw so that they
can check your anti-CCP titer.
That's another billing code
for rheumatoid arthritis.
And it may be that all
of this is negative
and you don't actually
have the disease.
So this is something that's
really important to think about
and to remember when you're
analyzing these data.
And so we started off
in this project saying,
well, we need to get a
positive predictive value
more on the order of 95%,
because we wanted a very
pure sample of people who really
did have the disease because we
were going to take blood
samples from those patients,
pay a bunch of money to
the Broad to analyze them,
and then hopefully
come up with a better
understanding of
the relationship
between their genetics
and their disease.
And of course, if you talk to
a biostatistician, as we did,
they told us that if we have
more than about 5% corruption
of that database, then
we're going to get
meaningless results from it.
So that's the goal here.
So what we did is
to say, well, if you
train a data set that tries
to tell you whether somebody
really has rheumatoid
arthritis or not
based on just codified data.
So codified data are things like
lab values and prescriptions
and demographics and stuff
that is in tabular form.
Then we were getting a positive
predictive value of about 88%.
We said, well, how
well could we do
by, instead of looking
at that codified data,
looking at the narrative text in
nursing notes, doctor's notes,
discharge summaries,
various other sources.
Could we do as well or better?
And the answer turned out
that we were getting about 89%
using only the natural language
processing on these notes.
And not surprisingly, when
you put them together,
the joint model
gave us about 94%.
So that was definitely
an improvement.
So this was published in 2010,
and so this is not the latest
hot off the bench results.
But to me, it's a
very compelling story
that says there is real value
in these clinical narratives.
OK, so how did we do this?
Well, we took about four
million patients in the EMR.
We selected about 29,000
of them by requiring
that they have at
least one ICD-9
code for rheumatoid
arthritis, or that they've
had an anti-CCP titer
done in the lab.
And then we-- oh,
it was 500, not 400.
So we looked at
500 cases, which we
got gold standard readings on.
And then we trained
an algorithm that
predicted whether this
patient really had RA or not.
And that predicted about 35--
well, 3,585 cases.
We then sampled a validation
set of 400 of those.
We threatened our
rheumatologists
with bodily harm if they
didn't read all those cases
and give us a gold
standard judgment.
No, I'm kidding.
They were actually
really cooperative.
And there are some
details here that you
can look at in the
slide, and I had
a pointer to the
original paper if you're
interested in the details.
But we were looking
at ICD-9 codes
for rheumatoid arthritis
and related diseases.
We excluded some
ICD-9 codes that
fall under the general
category of rheumatoid diseases
because they're not
correct for the sample
that we were interested in.
We dealt with this
multiple coding
by ignoring codes that happened
within a week of each other
so that we didn't get this
problem of multiple bills
from the same visit.
And then we looked for
electronic prescriptions
of various sorts.
We looked for lab tests,
mainly RF, rheumatoid factor,
and anti-cyclic
citrullinated peptide,
if I pronounced that correctly.
And another thing we found,
not only in this study
but in a number of others,
is it's very helpful
just to count up
how many facts are
on the database about
a particular patient.
That's not a bad proxy for
how sick they are, right?
If you're not very
sick, you tend
to have a little bit of data.
And if you're sicker, you
tend to have more data.
So these were the
cohort selection.
And then for the
narrative text, we
used a system that was built
by Qing Zeng and her colleagues
at the time-- it
was called HITex.
It's definitely not
state of the art today.
But this was a system
that extracted entities
from narrative text and did
a capable job for its era.
And we did this from health
care provider notes, radiology
and pathology reports, discharge
summaries, operative reports.
And we also extracted
disease diagnosis notes,
mentions from the same
data, medications,
lab data, radiology
findings, et cetera.
And then we had augmented the
list that came with that tool
with the sort of hand-curated
list of alternative ways
of saying the same thing in
order to expand our coverage.
And we played with
negation detection
because, of course, if a note
says the patient does not
have x, then you don't want to
say the patient had x because x
was mentioned.
And I'll say a few more
words about that in a minute.
So if you look at
the model we built
using logistic regression, which
is a very common method, what
you find is that there
are positive and negative
predictors, and the
predictors actually
are an interesting
mix of ones based
on natural language processing
and ones that are codified.
So for example, you have
rheumatoid arthritis.
If a note says the patient
has rheumatoid arthritis,
that's pretty good
evidence that they do.
If somebody is characterized
as being seropositive,
that's again good evidence.
And then erosions and so on.
But they're also
codified things,
like if you see that the
rheumatoid factor in a lab test
was negative, then--
actually, I don't
know why that's--
oh, no, that counts against--
OK.
And then various exclusions.
So these were the
things selected
by our regularized logistic
regression algorithm.
And I showed you
the results before.
So we were able to get a
positive predictive value
of about 0.94.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In a the
previous slide,
you said standardized
regression coefficients.
So why did you standardize?
Maybe I got the words wrong.
Just on the previous
slide, the--
PETER SZOLOVITS: I think--
so the regression coefficients
in a logistic regression
are typically just
odds ratios, right?
So they tell you whether
something makes a diagnosis
more or less likely.
And where does it
say standardized?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PETER SZOLOVITS: Oh,
regression standardized.
I don't know why it
says standardized.
Do you know why it
says standardized?
KATHERINE LIAO:
Couple of things.
One is, when you
run an algorithm
right on your data
set, you can't
port it using the same
coefficients because it's going
to be different for each one.
So we didn't want people to feel
like they can just add it on.
The other thing, when
you standardize it,
is you can see the relative
weight of each coefficient.
So it's kind of a measure.
Not exactly of how important
each coefficient was.
That's our way of--
if you can see,
we ranked it by the standardized
regression coefficient.
So NL PRA is up top at 1.11.
So that has the highest weight.
Whereas the other DMARDs lend
it only a little bit more.
PETER SZOLOVITS: OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The variables
where NL PRA, where
it says rheumatoid
arthritis in the test,
were these presence of
or if they're count?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
Assuming it's present.
So the negation
algorithm hopefully
would have picked up
if it said it's absent
and you wouldn't
get that feature.
All right?
So here's an interesting thing.
This group, I was not involved
in this particular project,
said, well, could we replicate
the study at Vanderbilt
and at Northwestern University?
So we have colleagues
in those places.
They also have electronic
medical record systems.
They also are interested
in identifying people
with rheumatoid arthritis.
And so Partners had
about 4 million patients,
Northwestern had 2.2,
Vanderbilt had 1.7.
And we couldn't run exactly the
same stuff because, of course,
these are different systems.
And so the medications,
for example,
were extracted from their local
EMR in very different ways.
And the natural language
queries were also
extracted in different
ways because Vanderbilt,
for example, already
had a tool in place
where they would
try to translate
any text in their
notes into UMLS
less concepts, which we'll talk
about again in a little while.
So my expectation, when
I heard about this study,
is that this would
be a disaster.
That it would simply
not work because there
are local effects,
local factors,
local ways that people
have of describing patients
that I thought would be very
different between Nashville,
Chicago, and Boston.
And much to my surprise, what
they found was that, in fact,
it kind of worked.
So the model performance,
even taking into account
that the way the data
was extracted out
of the notes and clinical
systems was different,
was fairly similar.
Now, one thing that
is worrisome is
that the PPV of our
algorithm on our data,
the way we calculated PPV, they
calculated PPV in this study,
came in lower than the way we
had done it when we found it.
And so there is a
technical reason for it,
but it's still
disturbing that we're
getting a different result.
The technical reason
is described here.
Here, the PPV is estimated from
a five-fold cross validation
of the data, whereas
in our study,
we had a held out data set
from which we were calculating
the positive predictive value.
So it's a different analysis.
It's not that we made
some arithmetic mistake.
But this is interesting.
And what you see is that if
you plot the areas under--
or if you plot the ROC
curves, what you see
is that training on
Northwestern data
and testing on either
Partners or Vanderbilt data
was not so good.
But training on either
Partners or Vanderbilt data
and testing on any of the others
turned out to be quite decent.
Right?
So there is some generality
to the algorithm.
All right, I'm going to
switch gears for a minute.
So this was from an old paper
by Barrows from 19 years ago.
And he was reading nursing
notes in an electronic medical
records system.
And he came up with
a note which has
exactly that text on the left
hand side in the nursing note.
Except it wasn't nicely
separated into separate lines.
It was all run together.
So what does that mean?
Anybody have a clue?
I didn't when I
was looking at it.
So here's the interpretation.
So that's a date.
IPN stands for
intern progress note.
SOB, that's not what
you think it means.
It's shortness of breath.
And DOE is dyspnea on exertion.
So this is difficulty breathing
when you're exerting yourself,
but that has
decreased, presumably
from some previous assessment.
And the patient's vital
signs are stable, so VSS.
And the patient is afebrile, AF.
OK?
Et cetera.
So this is harder than reading
the Wall Street Journal
because the Wall
Street Journal is
meant to be readable by
anybody who speaks English.
And this is probably not meant
to be readable by anybody
except the person
who wrote it or maybe
their immediate
friends and colleagues.
So this is a real issue
and one that we don't have
a very good solution for yet.
Now, what do you use NLP for?
Well, I had mentioned that one
of the things we want to do
is to codify things
that appear in a note.
So if it says
rheumatoid arthritis,
we want to say, well,
that's equivalent
to a particular ICD-9 code.
We might want to use
natural language processing
for de-identification of data.
I mentioned that before.
You don't, MIMIC, the only way
that Roger Mark's group got
permission to release
that data and make
it available for
people like you to use
is by persuading
the IRB that we had
done a good enough
job of getting
rid of all the identifying
information in all
of those records so that
it's probably not technically
impossible, but
it's very difficult
to figure out who the patients
actually were in that cohort,
in that database.
And the reason we ask you
to sign a data use agreement
is to deal with
that residual, you
know, difficult but not
necessarily impossible
because of correlations
with other data.
And then you have
little problems
like Mr. Huntington suffers from
Huntington's disease, in which
the first Huntington is
protected health information
because it's a patient's name.
The second Huntington
is actually
an important medical fact.
And so you wouldn't want
to get rid of that one.
You want to determine
aspects of each entity.
Its time, its location,
its degree of certainty.
You want to look
for relationships
between different entities that
are identified in the text.
For example, does one precede
another, does it cause it,
does it treat it, prevent
it, indicate it, et cetera?
So there are a whole bunch
of relationships like that
that we're interested in.
And then also, for certain
kinds of applications,
what you'd really like
to do is to identify
what part of a textual record
addresses a certain question.
So even if you can't
tell what the answer is,
you should able to point
to a piece of the record
and say, oh, this
tells me about,
in this case, the
patient's exercise regimen.
And then summarization
is a very real challenge
as well, especially because
of the cut and paste that
has come about as a result of
these electronic medical record
systems where, when a nurse
is writing a new note,
it's tempting and
supported by the system
for him or her to just
take the old note,
copy it over to a new note, and
then maybe make a few changes.
But that means that
it's very repetitive.
The same stuff is recorded
over and over again.
And sometimes that's
not even appropriate
because they may not
have changed everything
that needed to be changed.
The other thing to keep
in mind is that there
are two very different tasks.
So for example, if I'm
doing de-identification,
essentially I have to look
at every word in a narrative
in order to see whether it's
protected health information.
But there are often aggregate
judgments that I need to make,
where many of the words
don't make any difference.
And so for example, one
of the first challenges
that we ran back
in 2006 was where
we gave people medical
records, narrative text
records from a bunch
of patients and said,
is this person a smoker?
Well, you can imagine that
there are certain words that
are very helpful like
smoker or tobacco user
or something like that.
But even those are
sometimes misleading.
So for example, we
saw somebody who
happened to be a researcher
working on tobacco mosaic virus
who was not a smoker.
And then you have
interesting cases
like the patient quit
smoking two days ago.
Really?
Are they a smoker or not?
And also, aggregate judgment is
things like cohort selection,
where it's not every
single thing that you need
to know about this patient.
You just need to know if
they fit a certain pattern.
So let me give you a
little historical note.
So this happened to be work
that was done by my PhD thesis
advisor, the gentleman whose
picture is on the slide there.
And he published
this paper in 1966
called English for the Computer
in the Proceedings of the Fall
Joint Computer Conference.
This was the big computer
conference of the 1960s.
And his idea was that the
way to do English, the way
to process English is to
assume that there is a grammar,
and any English text
that you run across,
you parse according
to this grammar.
And that each parsing
rule corresponds
to some semantic function.
And so the picture that
emerges is one like this.
Where if you have
two phrases and they
have some syntactic relationship
between them, then you can
map each phrase to its meaning.
And the semantic relationship
between those two meanings
is determined by the syntactic
relationship in the language.
So this seems like a
fairly obvious idea,
but apparently nobody had tried
this on a computer before.
And so Fred built, over the
next 20 years, computer systems,
some of which I worked on that
tried to follow this method.
And he was, in fact,
able to build systems
that were used by researchers
in areas like anthropology,
where you don't have nice coded
data and where a lot of stuff
is in narrative text.
And yet he was able to
help one anthropologist
that I worked with at Caltech
to analyze a database of about
80,000 interviews that he had
done with members of the Gwembe
Tonga tribe, who lived in the
valley that is now flooded
by the Zambezi River Reservoir
on the border of Zambia
and Zimbabwe.
That was fascinating.
Again, he became very well
known for some of that research.
In the 1980s I was
amused to see that SRI--
which doesn't
stand for anything,
but used to stand for
Stanford Research Institute--
built a system called
Diamond Diagram,
which was intended
to help people
interact with the
computer system
when they didn't know a command
language for the computer.
So they could express what
they wanted to do in English
and the English
would be translated
into some semantic
representation.
And from that, the right thing
was triggered in the computer.
So these guys, Walker
and Hobbs, said, well,
why don't we apply this idea
to natural language access
to medical text?
And so they built a system
that didn't work very well,
but it tried to do this
by essentially translating
the English that it was reading
into some formal predicate
calculus representation
of what they saw, and then
a process for that system.
The original Diamond
Diagram system
that was built for people
who were naive computer users
and didn't know
command languages
actually had a
very rigid syntax.
And so what they
discovered is that people
are more adaptable
than computers
and that they could adapt
to this rigid syntax.
How many of you have
Google Home or Amazon Echo
or Apple something or
other that you deal with?
Well, so it's
training you, right?
Because it's not very good
at letting you train it,
but you're more adaptable.
And so you quickly learn that
if you phrase things one way,
it understands you, and if you
phrase things a different way,
it doesn't understand you.
And you learn how to phrase it.
So that's what these
guys are relying on,
is that they can
get people to adopt
the conventions that the
computer is able to understand.
The most radical
version of this was
a guy named de Heaulme,
who I met in 1983 in Paris.
He was a doctor Le
Pitie Salpetriere,
which is one of these
medieval hospitals in Paris.
And it's wonderful place,
although when they built it,
it was just a place to
die because they really
couldn't do much for you.
So de Heaulme convinced
the chief of cardiology
at that hospital that he would
develop an artificial language
for taking notes about
cardiac patients.
He would teach this
to all of the fellows
and junior doctors in
the cardiology department
at the hospital.
And they would be required
by the chief, which
is very powerful in France, to
use this artificial language
to write notes instead of
using French to write notes.
And they actually
did this for a month.
And when I met de
Heaulme, he was
in the middle of analyzing the
data that he had collected.
And what he found was
that the language was not
expressive enough.
There were things
that people wanted
to say that they couldn't say
in this artificial language he
had created.
And so he went back
to create version two,
and then he went back to
the cardiologist and said,
well, let's do this again.
And then they
threatened to kill him.
So the experiment
was not repeated.
OK, so back to term spotting.
Traditionally, if
you were trying
to do this, what you would
do is you would sit down
with a bunch of medical experts
and you would say, all right,
tell me all the
words that you think
might appear in a note that are
indicative of some condition
that I'm interested in.
And they would give
you a long list.
And then you'd do grep, you'd
search through the notes
for those terms.
OK?
And if you want it to
be really sophisticated,
you would use an
algorithm like NegEx,
which is a negation expression
detector that helps get rid
of things that are not true.
And then, as people
did this, they
said, well, there must be
more sophisticated ways
of doing this.
And so a whole industry
developed of people
saying that not only
should we use the terms
that we got originally
from the doctors who
were interested in
doing these queries,
but we can define a machine
learning problem, which
is how do we learn
the set of terms
that we should actually
use that will give us
better results than just
the terms we started with?
And so I'm going to talk about
a little bit of that approach.
First of all, for negation,
Wendy Chapman, now at Utah,
but at the time at Pittsburgh,
published this paper in 2001
called A Simple
Algorithm for Identifying
the Gated Findings of Diseases
in Discharge Summaries.
And it is indeed a
very simple algorithm.
And here's how it works.
You find all the UMLS
terms in each sentence
of a discharge summary.
So I'll talk a little
bit about that.
But basically, it's
a dictionary look up.
You look up in this very large
database of medical terms
and translate them into
some kind of expression
that represents what
that term means.
And then you find two
kinds of patterns.
One pattern is a negation phrase
followed within five words
by one of these UMLS terms.
And the other is a UMLS term
followed within five words
by a negation phrase, different
set of negation phrases.
So if you see no
sign of something,
that means it's not present.
Or if you see ruled out,
unlikely something, then it's
not present.
Absence of, not demonstrated,
denies, et cetera.
And post modifiers if you say
something declined or something
unlikely, that also indicates
that it's not present.
And then they hacked up a
bunch of exceptions where,
for example, if you
say gram negative, that
doesn't mean that it's negative
for whatever follows it
or whatever precedes it, right?
Et cetera.
So there are a
bunch of exceptions.
And what they found
is that this actually,
considering how
incredibly simple it is,
does reasonably well.
So if you look at sentences
that do not contain a negation
phrase and looked
at 500 of them,
you find that you get a
sensitivity and specificity
of 88% and 52% for
those that don't
contain one of these phrases.
Of course, the sensitivity
is 0 and the specificity
is 100% on the baseline.
And if you use
NegEx, what you find
is that you can significantly
improve the specificity
over the baseline.
All right?
And you wind up with
a better result,
although not in all schemes.
So what this means is that
very simplistic techniques
can actually work
reasonably well at times.
So how do we do
this generalization?
One way is to take advantage
of related terms like hypo-
or hypernyms, things
that are subcategories
or super categories of a word.
You might look for those
other associated terms.
For example, if you're looking
to see whether a patient has
a certain disease,
then you can do
a little bit of diagnostic
reasoning and say,
if I see a lot of symptoms
of that disease mentioned,
then maybe the disease
is present as well.
So the recursive
machine learning problem
is how best to identify
the things associated
with the term.
And this is generally
known as phenotyping.
Now, how many of you
have used the UMLS?
Just a few.
So in 1985 or '84, the
newly appointed director
of the National
Library of Medicine,
which is one of
the NIH institutes,
decided to make a big
investment in creating
this unified medical language
system, which was an attempt
to take all of the terminologies
that various medical
professional societies
had developed
and unify them
into a single, what
they called a meta-thesaurus.
So it's not really a
thesaurus because it's not
completely well integrated,
but it does include
all of this terminology.
And then they spent a lot
of both human and machine
resources in order
to identify cases
in which two
different expressions
from different terminologies
really meant the same thing.
So for example, myocardial
infarction and heart attack
really mean exactly
the same thing.
And in some
terminologies, it's called
acute myocardial
infarction or acute infarct
or acute, you know, whatever.
And they paid people
and they paid machines
to scour those entire
databases and come up
with the mapping
that said, OK, we're
going to have some concept,
you know, see 398752--
I just made that up--
which corresponds
to that particular concept.
And then they mapped
all those together.
So that's an enormous
help in two ways.
It helps you normalize databases
that come from different places
and that are
described differently.
It also tells you, for
natural language processing,
how it is--
it gives you a treasure
trove of ways of expressing
the same conceptual idea.
And then you can
use those in order
to expand the kinds of phrases
that you're looking for.
So there are, as of
the current moment,
there are about 3.7
million distinct concepts
in this concept base.
There are also hierarchies
and relationships
that are imported from all
these different sources
of terminology, but those
are a pretty jumbled mess.
And then over the whole thing,
they created a semantic network
that says there are 54
relations and 127 types,
and every concept
unique identifier
is assigned at least
one semantic type.
So this is very useful for
looking through this stuff.
Here are the UMLS semantic
concepts of various--
or the semantic types.
So you see that the most
common semantic type
is this T061, which stands
for therapeutic or preventive
procedure.
And there are 260,000 of those
concepts in the meta-thesaurus.
There are 233,000
findings, 172,000 drugs,
organic chemicals,
pharmacological substances,
amino acid peptide or
protein, invertebrate.
So the data does not come
only from human medicine
but also from veterinary
medicine and bioinformatics
research and all over the place.
But you see that these
are a useful listing
of appropriate semantic
types that you can then
look for in such a database.
And the types are
hierarchically organized.
So for example,
the relations are
organized so there's an
effects relation which
has sub-relations, manages,
treats, disrupts, complicates,
interacts with, or prevents.
Something like
biological function
can be a physiologic function
or a pathologic function.
And again, each of
these has subcategories.
So the idea is that each
concept, each unique concept
is labeled with at least
one of these semantic types,
and that helps to identify
things when you're
looking through the data.
There are also some
tools that deal
with the typical
linguistic problems,
that if I want to say
bleeds or bleed or bleeding,
those are really all
the same concept.
And so there are these
lexical variant generator
that helps us normalize that.
And then there is the
normalization function
that takes some statement like
Mr. Huntington was admitted,
blah, blah, blah,
and normalizes it
into lowercase alphabetized
versions of the text, where
things are translated into
other potential meanings,
linguistic meanings
of that text.
So for example, notice
this one says was,
but one of its translations
is be because was
is just a form of be.
This can also get
you in trouble.
I ran into a problem where
I was finding beryllium
in everybody's medical
records because it also
knows that b-e is an
abbreviation for beryllium.
And so you have to
be a little careful
about how you use this stuff.
There is an online tool where
you can type in something
and it says weakness of
the upper extremities.
And it says, oh, you
mean the concept proximal
weakness, upper extremities.
And then it has a relationship
to various contexts
and it has siblings and it
has all kinds of other things
that one can look up.
I built a tool a
few years ago where
if you populated with one
of the short summaries,
it tries to color code
the types of things
that it found in that summary.
And so this is
using a tool called
MetaMap, which again
comes from the National
Library of Medicine,
and a locally built UMLS
look up tool that in
this particular case
finds exactly the same
mappings from the text.
And so you can look through
the text and say, ah, OK,
so no indicates negation
and urine output
is a kind of one
of these concepts.
If you moused over
it, it would show you.
OK, I think what I'm going
to do is stop there today
so that I can invite Kat to
join us and talk about A, what's
happened since 2010, and B,
how is this stuff actually used
by clinicians and
clinician researchers.
Kat?
OK, well, welcome, Kat.
KATHERINE LIAO: Thank you.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Nice
to see you again.
So are the techniques
that were represented
in that paper from
nine years ago
still being used today
in research settings?
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah.
So I'd say yes, the
bare bones of platform--
that pipeline is being used.
But now I'd say we're
in version five.
Actually, you were on
that revision list.
But we've done a
lot of improvements
to actually automate
things a little more.
So the rate limiting
factor in phenotyping
is always the clinician.
Always getting that label,
doing the chart review,
coming up with that term list.
So I don't know if you want me
to go into some of the details
on what we've been doing.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
Yeah, if you would.
KATHERINE LIAO:
Kind of plugs it in.
So if you recall
that diagram, there
were several steps, where
you started with the EMR.
There was that filter
with the ICD codes.
Then you get this data mart,
and then you start training.
You had to select a random
500, which is a lot.
It's a lot of
chart review to do.
It is a lot.
So our goal was to reduce
that amount of chart review.
And part of the
way to reduce that
is reducing the feature space.
So one of the things that
we didn't know when we first
started out was how many gold
standard labels did we need
and how many
features did we need
and which of those features
would be important.
So by features, I mean ICD
codes, a diagnosis code,
medications, and all
that list of NLP terms
that might be related
to the condition.
And so now we have ways to
try to whittle down that list
before we even use those
gold standard labels.
And so let me think about--
this is NLP.
The focus here is on NLP.
So there are a couple of
ways we're doing this.
So one rate limiting step
was getting the clinicians
to come up with a
list of terms that
are important for a
certain condition.
You can imagine if you
get five doctors in a room
to try to agree on a
list, it takes forever.
And so we tried to get
that out of the way.
So one thing we
started doing was we
took just common things that
are freely available on the web.
Wikipedia, Medline,
the Merck Manual
that have medical information.
And we actually now
process those articles,
look for medical
terms, pull those out,
map them to concepts, and
that becomes that term list.
Now, that goes into--
so now instead of, if you
think about in the old days,
we came up with the list, we
had ICD lists and term lists,
which got mapped to a concept.
Now we go straight
to the article.
We kind of do majority
voting with the articles.
We take five articles,
if three out of five
mention it more than
x amount of time,
we say that could
potentially be important.
So that's the term list.
Get the clinicians
out of that step.
Well, actually, we
don't train yet.
So now instead of
training right away
in the gold standard
labels, we train
on a silver standard label.
Most of the time, we
use the main ICD code,
but sometimes we use
the main NLP [INAUDIBLE]
Because sometimes there is
no code for the phenotype
we're interested in.
So that's kind of
some of the steps
that we've done to automate
things a little bit more
and formalize that pipeline.
So in fact, the
pipeline is now part
of the Partners Biobank, which
is a Partner's Healthcare.
As Pete mentioned, it's Mass
General and Brigham Women's
Hospital.
They are recruiting patients
to come in and get the blood
sample, link it with their
notes so people can do research
on linked EHR data
and blood sample.
So this is the pipeline
they used for phenotyping.
Now I'm over at the Boston
VA along with Tianxi.
And this is the pipeline
we're laying down
for also the Million Veterans
program, which is even bigger.
It's a million
vets and they have
EHR data going back decades.
So it's pretty exciting.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
what are the kinds of--
I mean, this study that we
were talking about today
was for rheumatoid arthritis.
What other diseases are being
targeted by this phenotyping
approach?
KATHERINE LIAO: So
all kinds of diseases.
There's a lot of things
we learn, though.
The phenotyping approach is
best suited, the pipeline
that we-- the base
pipeline is best
suited for conditions that have
a prevalence of 1% or higher.
So rheumatoid arthritis is
kind of at that lower bound.
Rheumatoid arthritis is a
chronic inflammatory joint
disease.
It affects 1% of the population.
But it is the most common
autoimmune joint disease.
Once you go to rare
diseases that are
episodic that don't happen--
you know, not only
is it below 1%,
but only happens
once in a while--
this type of approach
is not as robust.
But most diseases are above 1%.
So at the VA, we've kind
of laid down this pipeline
for a phonemic score.
And they're running
through acute stroke,
myocardial infarction, all
kinds of these-- diabetes--
just really a lot of
all the common diseases
that we want to study.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Now,
you were mentioning
that when you identify
such a patient,
you then try to get a
blood sample so that you
can do genotyping on them.
Is that also common
across all these diseases
or are there
different approaches?
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah,
so it's interesting.
10 years ago, it
was very different.
It was very expensive
to genotype a patient.
It was anywhere between
$500 to $700 per patient.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And that was
just for single nucleotide
polymorphism.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yes,
just for a snip.
So we had to be very careful
about who we selected.
So 10 years ago, what
we did is we said,
OK, we have 4 million
patients and partners.
Who has already
with good certainty?
Then we select those patients
and we genotype them.
Because it costs
so much, you didn't
want to genotype someone
who didn't have RA.
Not only would it alter the--
it would reduce the power
of our association study,
it would just be
like wasted dollars.
The interesting thing is
that the change has happened.
And we can completely
think of a different way
of approaching things.
Now you have these biobanks.
You have something like
the VA MVP or UK Biobank.
They are being
systematically recruited,
blood samples are
taken, they're genotyped
with no study in mind.
Linked with the EHR.
So now I walk into the VA, it's
a completely different story.
10 years later, I'm
at the VA and I'm
interested in identifying
rheumatoid arthritis.
Interesting enough,
this algorithm
ports well over there, too.
But now we tested our
new method on there.
But now, instead of saying, I
need to identify these patients
and get the genotype, all the
genotypes are already there.
So it's a completely different
approach to research now.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Interesting.
So the other question
that I wanted
to ask you before
we turn it over
to questions from
the audience is,
so this is all focused on
research uses of the data.
Are there clinical
uses that people
have adopted that use
this kind of approach
to trying to read the note?
We had fantasized
decades ago that,
you know, when you get a
report from a pathologist,
that somehow or other, a
machine learning algorithm
using natural
language processing
would grovel over it, identify
the important things that
came out, and then
either incorporate
that in decision support or in
some kind of warning systems
that drew people's attention
to the important results as
opposed to the unimportant ones.
Has any of that happened?
KATHERINE LIAO: I think
we're not there yet,
but I feel like we're so much
closer than we were before.
That's probably how you
felt a few decades ago.
One of the challenges
is, as you know,
EHR weren't really widely
adopted until the HITEx Act
in 2010.
So a lot of systems are actually
now just getting their EHR.
And the reason that we've had
the luxury of playing around
with the data is because
Partners was ahead of the curve
and had developed an EHR.
The VA happened to have an EHR.
But I think first--
because research and clinical
medicine is very different.
Research, if you mess up
and you misclassify someone
with a disease, it's OK, right?
You just lose power
in your study.
But in the clinical
setting, if you mess up,
it's a really big deal.
So I think the bar
is much higher.
And so one of our goals
with all this phenotyping
is to get it to that point
where we feel pretty confident.
We're not going to say someone
has or hasn't a disease,
but we are, you
know, Tianxi and I
have been planning
this grant where,
what's outputted
from this algorithm
is a probability of disease.
And some of our phenotype
algorithms are pretty good.
And so what we want to
test is what threshold
is that probability
that you would want
to tell a clinician
that, hey, if you're not
thinking about rheumatoid
arthritis in this patient--
this is particularly
helpful in places
where they're in
remote locations
where there aren't
rheumatologist
available-- you should
be thinking about it
and maybe, you know,
considering referring them
or speaking to a rheumatologist
through telehealth,
which is also something.
There's a lot of things
that are changing
that are making
something like this fit
much more into the workflow.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
So you're as optimistic
as I was in the 1990s.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yes.
I think we're getting--
we'll see.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Well,
you know, it will surely
happen at some point.
Did any of you go
to the festivities
around the opening
of the Schwarzman
College of Computing?
So they've had a
lot of discussions.
And health care does keep
coming up over and over again
as one of the great
opportunities.
I profoundly believe that.
But on the other hand, I've
learned over many decades
not to be quite as optimistic
as my natural proclivities are.
And I think some of the
speakers here have not yet
learned that same lesson.
So things may take
a little bit longer.
So let me open up the
floor to questions.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the mapping
that you did to concepts,
is that within the
Partners system
or is that something
like publicly available?
And can you just
transfer that to the VA?
Or like, when you do work
like, how much is proprietary
and how much gets expanded up?
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah.
So you're speaking about
when we were trying
to create that term
list and we mapped
the terms to the concepts?
AUDIENCE: And you
were using Wikipedia
and three other sources.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah.
Yeah.
So that's all out there.
So as an academic group, we try
to publish everything we do.
We put our codes up on GitHub
or CRAN for other people
to play out and tests and break.
So yeah, the terms are
really similar in UMLS.
I don't know if you had a
chance to look through it.
They have a lot of keywords.
So there is a general way to map
keywords to terms to concepts.
So that's the basis
of what we do.
There may maybe a
little bit more there,
but there's nothing
fancy behind it.
And as you can
imagine, because we're
trying to go across
many phenotypes,
when we think about mapping,
it always has to be automated.
Our first round was very
manual, incredibly manual.
But now we try to use
systems that are available
such as UMLS and
other mapping methods.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So what map--
presumably, you don't
use HITex today.
KATHERINE LIAO: No.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So
which tools do you use?
KATHERINE LIAO: Just thinking
I had a two hour conversation
with Oakridge about this.
We're using a system that
Cheng developed called NIAL.
And it had to do with the
fact that cTAKES, which
is a really robust system,
was just too computationally
intensive.
And for the purposes
of phenotyping,
we didn't need that
level of detail.
What we really needed
was, was it mentioned,
what's the concept,
and the negation.
And so NIAL is something
that we've been using
and have kind of validated over
time with the different methods
we've been testing.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
So Tuesday, I'll
talk a little bit
about that system
and some of its successors.
So you'll get a sense
of how that works.
I should mention also that
one of the papers that
was on your reading
list is a paper out
of David Sontag's group, which
uses this anchorous concept.
And that's very much
along the same lines.
That it's a way of
trying to automate,
just as Kat was
saying, you know,
if the doctor's
mention some term
and you discover that that
term is very often used
with certain other
terms by looking
at Wikipedia or at
the Mayo Clinic data
or wherever your
sources are, then
that's a good clue that
that other term might also
be useful.
So this is a
formalization of that idea
as a machine learning problem.
So basically, that
paper talks about how
to take some very
certain terms that
are highly indicative
of a disease
and then use those
as anchors in order
to train a machine
learning model
that identifies more terms that
are also likely to be useful.
So this notion of--
and David talked about a similar
idea in a previous lecture,
where you get a silver standard
instead of a gold standard.
And the silver
standard can be derived
from a smaller gold
standard using some machine
learning algorithm.
And then you can use that in
your further computations.
AUDIENCE: So what
was the process
like for partnering with
academics and machine learning?
So did you seek them out,
did they seek you out?
Did you run into each
other at the bus stop?
How does that work?
KATHERINE LIAO: Well,
I was really lucky.
There was a big study called
The Informatics for Integrating
Biology and the Bedside Project
called i2B2 led by Zak Kohane
And so that was
already in place.
And Pete had already been
pulled in and Tianxi.
So what they basically
did was locked all us
in a room for three
hours every Friday.
And it was like, what's the
problem, what's the question,
and how do we get there.
And so I think that
infrastructure was so helpful
in bringing everyone
to the table,
because it's not easy
because you're not
rotating in the same space.
And the way you think
is very different.
So that's how we did it.
Now it's more mainstream.
I think when we first
started, everyone was--
my colleagues joked with me.
They're like, what
are you doing?
R2D2?
What's going on?
Are you going off the
deep end over there?
Because you know, the
type of research we do
was more along the ways of
clinical trials and clin-epi
projects.
But now, you know, we have--
I run a core at Brigham.
So it's run out of the
rheumatology division.
And so we kind of try to
connect people together.
I did post to our core the
consulting session here.
But you know, if
there is interest,
there's probably more
groups that are doing this,
where we can kind of more
formally have joint talks
or connect people together.
Yeah.
But it's not easy.
I have to say, it
takes a lot of time.
Because when Pete put
up that thing in what
looked like a different
language, I mean,
it didn't even occur to me that
it was hard to read, right?
So it's like, you know,
you're into these two
different worlds.
And so you have to work
to meet in the middle,
and it takes time.
PETER SZOLOVITS: It also
takes the right people.
So I have to say
that Zak was probably
very clever in bringing the
right people to the table
and locking those into that
room for three hours at a time
because, for example,
our biostatistician,
Tianxi Cai just, you
know, she speaks AI
or she has learned to speak AI.
And there are still
plenty of statisticians
who just have allergic
reactions to the kinds
just things that we do,
and it would be very
difficult to work with them.
So having the right
combination of people
is also really I think critical.
KATHERINE LIAO: As one
of my mentors said,
you have to kiss a lot of frogs.
AUDIENCE: I wondering if you
could say a bit more about how
you approached the
alarm fatigue with how
you balance [INAUDIBLE] question
around how certain you are
versus clinical questions of how
important this is versus even
psychological questions
of, I said is too often
to a certain amount of people.
They're going to
start [INAUDIBLE]??
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah,
you've definitely
hit the nail on the head of
one of the major barriers,
or several things.
The alarm fatigue
is one of them.
So EMRs became more
prominent in 2010.
But now, along with
EMRs came a lot
of regulations on physicians.
And then came getting
rid of our old systems
for these new systems that
are now government compliant.
So Epic is this
big monster system
that's being rolled out
across the country, where
you literally have--
it's so complicated
in places like Mayo.
They hire scribes.
The physicians
sits in the office
and there's another person
who actually listens in
and types and then
clicks all the buttons
that you need to get
the information there.
So alarm fatigue is definitely
one of the barriers.
But the other
barrier is the fact
that the EMRs are so
user-unfriendly now.
They're not built
for clinical care.
They're built for billing.
We have to be careful
about how we roll this out.
And that's one reason why I
think things have been held up,
actually.
Not necessarily the science.
It's the implementation part
is going to be very hard.
PETER SZOLOVITS: So that
isn't new, by the way.
I remember a class I taught
in biomedical computing
about 15 years ago.
David Bates, who's the chief
of general internal medicine
or something at the
Brigham, came in
and gave a guest lecture.
And he was describing
their experience
with a drug-drug
interaction system
that they had implemented.
And they purchased a data
set from a vendor called
First Databank that had
scoured the literature
and found all the instances
where people had reported cases
where a patient taking both this
medication and that medication
had an apparent adverse event.
So there was some
interaction between them.
And they bought this
thing, they implemented it,
and they discovered that, on
the majority of drug orders
that they were making through
their pharmacy system,
a big red alert would pop up
saying, you know, are you aware
of the fact that there is
a potential interaction
between this drug
and some other drug
that this patient is taking.
And the problem is that the
incentives for the company that
curated this
database were to make
sure they didn't miss
anything, because they
didn't want to be responsible
for failing to alarm.
But of course,
there's no pushback
saying that if you warn
on every second order,
then no one's going to pay
any attention to any of them.
And so David's
solution was to get
a bunch of the senior
doctors together
and they did some study of what
actual adverse events had they
experienced at the hospital.
And they cut this list of
thousands of drug interactions
down to 20.
And they said, OK,
those are the only ones
we're going to alarm on.
KATHERINE LIAO: And
then they threw that
out when Epic came in.
So now I put in an order,
I get like a list of 10
and I just click them all.
So that's the problem.
And the threshold
is going to be--
so there's going
to be an entire--
I think there's going
to be entire methods
development that's going to have
to happen between figuring out
where that threshold is and
the fatigue from the alarms.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One is about [INAUDIBLE].
Like how did you approach that
because we talk about this
in other contexts in class?
And the other one
is, like, how can you
inform other countries
[INAUDIBLE] done here?
Because, I mean, at
the end of the day,
it's a global health issue.
And also drug
systems are different
even between the US and the UK.
So all the mapping
we're doing here,
how could that inform
EHR or elsewhere?
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah.
So let me answer the first one.
The second one is
a work in progress.
So ICD-10 came to the
US on October 1, 2015.
I remember.
It hurt us all.
So we actually don't have that
much information on ICD-10 yet.
But it's definitely
impacted our work.
So if you think about
when Pete was pointing
to the number of ICD counts
for ICD-9, for those of you who
don't know, ICD-9 was
developed decades ago.
ICD-10 maybe two decades ago.
But what ICD-10 did was
it added more granularity.
So for rheumatoid
arthritis, I mentioned
it's a systemic chronic
inflammatory joint disease.
We used to have a code that
said rheumatoid arthritis.
In ICD-10, it now says
rheumatoid arthritis,
rheumatoid factor positive,
rheumatoid factor negative.
And under each category
is RA of the right wrist,
RA of the left wrist, RA of
the right knee, left knee.
Can you imagine?
So we're clicking
off all of these.
And so, as it turns
out, surprisingly--
we're about to publish
a small study now,
is RA any more accurate now
they have all these granular--
it turns out, I
think we got annoyed
because it's actually less
accurate now than the ICD-9.
So that's one thing.
But that's, you know, only
two or three years of data.
I think it's going to
become pretty equivalent.
The other thing is,
you'll see an explosion
in the number of ICD codes.
So you have to think about how
do you deal with back October
1, 2015 when you
had one RA code,
but after 2015, it depends
on when the patient comes in.
They may have RA of the
right wrist on one day,
then on the left
knee the other day.
That looks like
a different code.
So right now, we have to
think of systematic systems
to roll up.
I think the biggest challenge
right now is the mapping.
So ICD-9, you know, doesn't
map directly to ICD-10 or back
because there were
diseases that we
didn't know when they developed
ICD-9 that exist in ICD-10.
In ICD-10, they talk about
diseases in ways that
weren't described in ICD-9.
So when you're trying
to harmonize the data,
and this is actively something
we're dealing with right now
at the VA, how do you
now count the ICD codes?
How do you consider that
someone has an ICD code for RA?
So those are all things that
are being developed now.
CMS, Center for
Medicaid and Medicare,
again, this is for
billing purposes,
has come up with a mapping
system that many of us
are using now,
given what we have.
PETER SZOLOVITS: And by
the way, the committee
that is designing ICD-11 has
been very active for years.
And so there is another
one coming down the pike.
Although, from
what I understand--
KATHERINE LIAO: Are
you involved with that?
PETER SZOLOVITS: No.
But Chris Chute is or was.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yes, I saw.
I said, don't do it.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
Well, but actually,
I'm a little bit
optimistic because
unlike the traditional
ICD system,
this one is based on SNOMED,
which has a much more
logical structure.
So you know, my
favorite ICD-10 code
is closed fracture
of the left femur
due to spacecraft accident.
KATHERINE LIAO: I didn't
even know that existed.
PETER SZOLOVITS:
As far as I know,
that code has never
been applied to anybody.
But it's there just in case.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So wait,
for the ICD-11
you don't think take that
long to exist because it's
a more logical system?
PETER SZOLOVITS: So ICD-11--
well, I don't know
what it's going
to be because they
haven't defined it yet.
But the idea behind
SNOMED is that it's more
a combinatorial system.
So it's more like a
grammar of descriptions
that you can assemble according
to certain rules of what
assemblies make sense.
And so that means
that you don't have
to explicitly mention something
like the spacecraft accident
one.
But if that ever
arises, then there
is a way to construct
something that
would describe that situation.
KATHERINE LIAO: I ran
into Chris at a meeting
and he said something
along the lines
that he thinks it's going
to be more NLP-based, even.
I don't know.
Is it going to be
more like a language?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Well,
you need to ask him.
KATHERINE LIAO:
Yeah, I don't know.
He hints at it [INAUDIBLE].
I was like, OK, this
will be interesting.
PETER SZOLOVITS: I
think it's definitely
more like a language,
but it'll be more
like the old Fred Thompson
or the Diamond Diagram
kind of language.
It's a designed
language that you're
going to have to learn in order
to figure out how to describe
things appropriately.
Or at least your billing
clerk will have to learn it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I know
we're towards the end.
But I had a question about
when a clinician is trying
to label data, for
example, training data,
are there any ambiguities
ever, where sometimes this
is definitely--
this person has RA.
This person, I'm
not really sure.
How do you take
that into account
when you're actually
training a [INAUDIBLE]??
KATHERINE LIAO: Yeah.
So we actually have three
categories-- definite,
possible, and no.
So there is always ambiguity.
And then you always want to
have more than one reviewer.
So in clinical trials
when you have outcomes,
you have what we
call adjudication.
So you have some
kind of system where
you have the first sit down, you
have to define the phenotype.
Because not everybody
is going to agree, even
for a really clear disease,
how do you define the disease.
What are the components
that has to happen.
For that, they're usually for
societies or classification
criteria for research.
So there actually
is one for RA, you
know, for coronary
artery disease.
And then it is having
those different categories
in a very structured
system for adjudicating.
You know, blindly having two
reviewers review 20, you know,
let's say 20 of the
same notes and look
at the integrated reliability.
Yeah.
That's a big issue.
PETER SZOLOVITS: All right.
I think we have expired.
So Kat, thank you very much.
KATHERINE LIAO: Yes,
thank you, everybody.